before you ever knew me I wasn't scared
much I wasn't a feel for me I'll be back
it was kid my kids my wife my whole
brains bunch of missing pieces mister
mr. ice where have you sat back over the
last two decades and thought about the
sheer number of fatalities surrounding
this case what happened can tell you a
secret I used to be something of a mess
that might be the least surprising thing
I've ever heard
what about you your clip-on ties as
crazy as you get no god no but I'd like
to pretend normal with you as long as I
can't for blaze that you've been killer
[Music]
after one of those
we'll enjoy I can't find him anywhere
that's what it all started with the tail
[Music]
I'm writing about the investigation now
as much about us as in advance and I
think you use people like we're all
stories to you
I'm gonna stop Wayne
[Music]
it's like a thing staring right at us
you got that feeling myself
you know it's just a case when our car
there no it'd be my last
with you I need to know everything
things you better off not not
we'll stop all right
finish it
you